hi guys so we all know what five nights
at Freddy's is but this game is called
five nights in heaven and that sounds
much more than my cup of tea apparently
this game is some sort of a dating
simulator let's go find me some
good-looking animatronics cuz that's
definitely what I'm into yeah okay start
the game would you like to run through a
quick tutorial mmm tutorial yeah welcome
to five nights in heaven this is like
five nights at Freddy's fan game that
works like a dating simulator cool in
fact it is a dating simulator oh my gosh
the moment you set foot inside your
office you will see two things power
okay so the battery is back these are
important as they will show you exactly
how much power you have left and how
many hours you have left to survive the
night I'm surviving nights in a dating
simulator I thought this game wasn't
gonna be scary
no it's not scarier there's gonna be fun
this power runs for five bars not one
thing is not fun okay allow me to open
up your karma for a moment okie dokie
this looks very familiar this is the
camera screen from here you view the
animatronics they wander around the
restaurant in the bottom right so
there's a map this shows you the layout
the building oh it's just yeah yeah I
know all this having followed all of
them but that's pretty much the tutorial
as per normal 5 X Freddy style a foam
guy will teach you everything else you
need to know Oh foam guy
[Music]
just like five nights at freddys morning
this game features flashing lights and
jump scares if your upper lip see it's
not good or assets from five nights at
Freddy's five minutes in heaven
oh so it is jump scares brilliant guys
it's another horror game I thought I
didn't think it was gonna be alright
time to stop my new job let's find a
boyfriend where's my office ah there it
is hello office what a cute little
cupcake sky huh I wonder if that cute
guys in the company will phone me I'd
love to learn some new things PIM yeah
it's totally me when I'm crushing over
someone huh hello hi I think Dodger I'm
up here already
you really don't miss a minute of work
do you I definitely try not to all right
well hey I have a little greeting from
the company here if you don't mind me
reading it yeah go ahead
all right hmm welcome to Freddy
fazbear's pizza a magical place for kids
and grown-ups alike where fantasy and
fun come tonight
bad parents David snaps pencils the
damage of property present from the
discovery the damage or death is cutter
uh a missing person report we found
within 90 days or as soon as a promise
of a rollover and the carpets have been
replaced cough now that might sound bad
this is literally exactly what he said
in the first one might that sounds
terrible i wor yes yes it does they says
please don't hey these things on this
when you sign up that's that's my line
oh well I suppose this won't be too safe
a job will it to be honest I don't think
so don't ever say I mentioned this but
back in 1987 there was an incident
involving the animatronics people call
it the bite of 87 I've been reading up
on this on Wikipedia on Finance of
Freddy's PD and whatever it's called
that's all terrible yeah it's amazing to
know that the human body can live
without the
Loeb yeah I so not really you know yeah
it's all speculation about what happened
to the frontal lobe I think it was foxy
because foxy is terrifying
anyway concerning your safety you just
know that the animatronic characters
wonder a bit a lot actually I've worked
in the office for five years now I'm so
glad this is my last week to be honest
well I'm glad you get out thanks I wish
you all the best
I'll call you tomorrow at 12 on the dots
okie dokie then tell me what about the
angle to us Peugeot tell me well them
yeah there are four here the names are
Bonnie chica foxy and well Freddy of
course for being robots they seem to
have individual personalities their own
as though they can feel it's amazing
when you think about it
phony tends to hang around the dining
area I suppose that puts you at a time
when it's a party you'll be alone I
guess you just like the same place at
night chica don't stay in the kitchen
bla foxes in Park Cove Freddy's kind of
different if he's ever off stage he'll
either be in the Johnny air or the
kitchen okay this is getting boring
that's all the guy sleep goodbye goodbye
I feel lonely Oh already
Oh what's the screen here for wow this
is so cool
are these the Adriatic sure motif or
there's really dumb girls on the horror
movies hi there what was that
hey there but for Freddy guys there's a
need for friend to kill wait no this
isn't the ghoul anymore this is question
mark new friend hailey oh hello why did
I jump
oh so stupid they were our friend oh no
they're active what do I do
oh okay right so it's one of these what
do I do
um I watch them sigh okay I can do this
watch the cameras and I will be fine oh
no there's only one there what do I do
I will check the backstage I should look
for Bonnie he must be around here
somewhere there you are
found you what Oh mine is this keep
happening where could he be going hi
there hello what's your name friend
hi oh did I scare you
my name is Bonnie it's nice to meet you
I may I come in uh is he gonna fight
with me
Wow it's sure cramped in here sorry for
being right in your face like this yeah
it's um I said it's fine it's totally
cool I like your company I see you're a
pretty good-looking girl oh but you're
not so bad just that I don't want it I
don't want to wholesomer it make him mad
at me I don't want to offend him that's
the one
oh well oh no that's me oh you're not so
bad yourself funny room I'll be singing
around milady ah I think he's a
gentleman wow what a creep he's gone now
I can be mean
Oh ninety-four he thinks I like him huh
it's 6:00 a.m. time to head he turns it
with one animatronic that was pretty
weird
well the hell am i doing tonight she's
not available but I was expecting
something way cooler than that I were at
a flat with things and
oh let me try this again hey friend why
it is so okay let's try and pick up the
phone ring ring oh come on ringing hello
I'll thank God you picked up what are
you doing you realize it's still only 1
a.m. right yeah well um I just love the
sound of your voice it's comforting oh
well thank you I guess
it's just that look if you're trying to
flirt with me oh wait no I was it's just
that I'm not exactly in the mood I'm
sorry you're a nice girl and all but
he's gonna reject me I'm professional oh
okay I'm sorry
yeah me too good night click Oh sigh
that didn't turn out well I suppose I
just have to wait it out tonight
[Applause]
very strange strange Oh strange this try
again okay right so I watch then I
should look out for chica yeah I think
she's in here I can hear her I don't
think I need to worry about her it's
gonna show stage it's gonna show stage
huh nothing happening what is that music
ha hi oh no the camera feed cut out huh
I need to try and find him
check my office Oh God ah
let's hit the hall I should check the
hall make sure he doesn't get too close
hmm nothing here oh oh he didn't even
fight with me say oh where am I huh
who's there
it's
why are you here I I work here
it's my job oh but that's me
please Freddie don't kill me who said I
was going to kill you hmm
what'd you do I won't kill you dearie I
just wanted to talk to you uh okay
you're scared very perceptive Freddie
don't worry I don't plan on hurting you
calm down where am i right welcome to
the kitchen sorry about the mess
what do you like any pizza ah sounds
like a proper gentleman
um no thanks why did you say no ask him
if it's little stuff crossing it I see
well I suppose I should let you go now
it seems like you don't want to be here
[Music]
no I want to stay you seem like a lovely
guy you offer me pizza oh you want to
stay after all yes you've intrigued me
okay what is this I'm making the eyes of
them you intrigue me you know I have a
sort of brother
dear he's quite a load of fun if I do
say so myself
well besides his rather limp lifeless
appearance maybe you'd like to meet him
sometime I don't understand ha
don't worry about it you should head
home
we must power down now I'll see you
tomorrow night this is a game
far too weird I think I'm going to leave
it there because that that Freddie one
was very very hard but it was quite fun
and I still screamed why the hell did I
still scream anyway I hope you enjoyed
this it's just a little weird thing that
I wanted to try out for you guys if you
want to try fighting with some
animatronics yourselves and I will put a
link to this in the description below
it's free to download so go for it I
hope you have a lovely day or evening
bye I don't know what I am supposed to
do okay and if everything is online oh
my geez
Oh